[Music]
tell me a little bit about the
the hall of fame tell me about the whole
thing you know halloween
i'm born how you hall of fame at 22 come
on
man i'm coming one day
[Music]
what's up everybody welcome to this
episode of hot boxing with mike tyson
i'm your co-host triple c
aka henry cejudo and i'm mike tyson man
we got [ __ ] polo g in here man
gang
so talk to us polo man you're from
chinatown when you start doing this man
you're 22 now you said
yeah i just turned 22 in january how
long you've been doing this
like uh i first started rapping i could
remember i made my first rap when i was
like nine
i uh went to the studio for the first
time when i turned 17.
i shot my first video at 18
and i got signed approaching three years
ago
how did you get discovered but i want to
know what [ __ ] is happening good for you
where's the hard times
i'm used to rapidly ass [ __ ] with all i
can get through
couldn't get signed now it kind of
happened fast though because oh [ __ ]
because it was really like me utilizing
youtube
to my advantage on uh social media like
i was on facebook heavy to
gain the fan base starting out do you
love the [ __ ] letter
face book [ __ ] has got me [ __ ] up
yeah you know you hear show your faith
do some crazy [ __ ] and 100 million
people know you
yeah a little bit like that ain't that a
trip but i think i think in his
generation mike
like these guys are more uh it's just
it's a different attention
right it's a different gravitation to
the eye that's what they have been able
to master at a
for their for their generation am i
right yeah for sure
tell me about your brothers and sisters
you have an older sister right
yeah i got i got one older sister she 24
and then i got a younger brother he
about 16. he'd be rapping too his name
trend he's in your crew though he got
his own crew
yeah you could say that we we gonna say
what's the same crew that's my brother
sister do any rapping any kind of music
yeah my sister do music
too but she ain't really dropped the
first song again my my brother got music
on youtube ain't helping this [ __ ] yeah
yeah i'll be um
pushing her to get in the studio she
just like our own biggest critic
you know but she the one reason i do
music i used to look up to her
doing it and um i got a younger sister
too her name leia
she about eight years old oh [ __ ] little
baby yeah
since you got how many awards you ever
win the one the choice awards with the
kids and all that stuff
now as far as the wars go i ain't no i
never want none
never been source awards and all that
stuff yeah no nothing that's coming your
way soon
for sure talk to me about the chain on
your neck man 13.
1300 this the block i'm from
from 1300 block up north on the north
side of chicago
everybody know that too huh yeah look
good
because i've been watching i'm kind of
curious i don't know if you've seen it
i think we talked about it mike you ever
seen that you ever seen a tv show called
the
the shy yeah that was sly i watched
like an episode or two before but i
never got into it i don't really watch
tv
the show is really fly i i think it
could be good but i think it's i don't
know you know
obviously you're from chicago but this
takes place i think in particular the
south side
if he doesn't see where he's going he
just think he's gonna be hip-hop but you
gonna be in movies and [ __ ] now y'all
want to act one day it's just like right
now i'm too shy for that
that's what you're gonna do though okay
ain't you that's gonna happen you'll be
acting rapping
acting like you're
[Laughter]
the rapping who were who are some of
your biggest influences as a
as a rapper man that you uh that you
admire and that that have inspired you
you know to
come up with your own flows and things
like that your swagger
wayne of course i just
actually released the song with him like
a week ago uh wayne
it's going crazy on that it's called
game game okay let's
let's see it what's up pull it up i
forgot
and then um anybody outside of that i
could say just the chicago uprise in
general
[Music]
i'm just trying to put a lock on the
game
[Music]
only way a [ __ ] looking down on me keep
at least 200 on me
keep at least like 30 rounds on me when
my [ __ ] to the wheels fall off
don't
this video dude it's well produced bro
this thing is fire got some
budget huh [ __ ] yeah
and my label know they got my wife said
my wife saw your commercial with the
coins
oh he got budget what's up
yeah that is quality
my wife used to be wardrobe for these
guys the rappers and stuff she's doing
the
oh yeah yeah that's cool man with these
videos
do you guys uh this is a little movie
one of the miniature movies yeah but i
wanted do you guys choreograph this
stuff or do you kind of just you just go
with the beating whenever you feel you
kind of you know
you mimic or you do it depends on how
into the song i
am like and i'm not just i'm gonna say
like
i ain't got none of my songs that i put
out that i don't like
but it's like the ones that i hold
closer to me like
it had a deeper meaning behind it i got
a vision behind it too but nobody's over
there say hey do it like this right
no no yeah nobody's instructing you how
to do this right
yeah not necessarily that can give me
pointless but most
[Music]
how was the filming for this bro was it
fun dude those are the fun experiences
you're having huh
right now like reaching success is doing
a video with lil wayne and things like
that
hell yeah it was fun it was like really
not until i got back home
like i noticed how surreal it was to be
doing a video with wayne
like i was just sitting there like i
used to hang out with these guys in
louisiana i know he was 16 years old he
didn't say a word
i can't stop him from talking
[Laughter]
but uh tupac he was another big
inspiration tupac was one of mike's good
friends
yeah yeah i i i really didn't get up on
to tupac
until i was older like probably like at
my teenage
and then that's when i started to really
discover like what he was about
you you have you have four hundred
million
streams on spotify right he's out man
how do you feel about that
everybody clocking you every move i mean
it's something that i work towards
i really like more so humble about it
though what what's
the song that really rogers name like do
you have your number one man that you
really uh
that kind of speaks to your heart like
my favorite song of mine
right now uh epidemic epidemic let's
play that [ __ ]
yeah that's probably the favorite
something what's what's behind that one
that uh
because you're you're a poet man like
you know what i'm saying you you know
it's not just about
you yeah i don't really
like i can't really put my finger on it
feel like i just spoke my mind and this
was in the middle of the quarantine
like when a uh when the pandemic first
started
oh no i really just spoke my mind
[Music]
i'm so sick of farewells and rrp in the
trenches yelling gang gang mom ties what
i bleed
don't claim to be a hop cause [ __ ] die
from that disease he gonna let that now
blow it
can i speak my mind can i breathe i know
she might cry if i leave
i've been fooled by liars and thieves i
stop my rollie but i know time cannot
freeze
once you get my [ __ ] this is fly
hanging out with your crew designer gear
on
where's the second
do you direct this yeah as far as like
settings yes yeah i put that together
but it's like um i really been doing
that since i started rapping though
because
early on i used to um do the management
like handle my own management and i
didn't really have nobody helping me at
mike
the first place 500 bucks 500.
has a pro and a heavyweight jesus man
but how you only make 500 i really made
nothing somebody took 500 bucks out of
their pocket and gave it to me
but i just love fighting i will fight
for nothing
and they can't want the world to see me
because once they see me i know they're
going to stop paying for me
[Music]
yeah but then again the flip side that
turned into a whole lot more than that
oh absolutely
for sure who was your biggest payday
mike i had quite a few
yeah like 35
five that's a lot of money yeah
but i make that now i'm 55 [ __ ]
that's back in the 90s too so i would be
like almost like 100 maybe
maybe close to you know what i'm saying
what would that be an equivalent
trying to write us off can't get rid of
me gee
they can't get rid of me i sort of did a
story about this all those haters
and it's also jealous of me gee because
your girl be in jail or dead by now gee
look what i'm doing
i'm talking to you on my show i'm
talking to you
yeah yeah this is me so
uh you do a little bit of philanthropy
too huh you brought in
the aau into the city of chicago
tell me about the aau hell yeah um
i started my team i'm really funny to
get back in the field my team this
summer
the corona slowed that thing down but i
had an athlete
i used to play basketball a little when
i was uh
coming up but um i had visited my um
childhood school and they told me they
ain't have an aau team
so that's when i put it together had
tryouts
a lot of the kids from my neighborhood i
sent out flies made sure they came
and we kickstarted it like that how many
teams do you have
i got a section for the younger kids and
then a section for the older kids
in high school and then some for like
middle schoolers and stuff like that
it's just split up into two really but
it's still within all
under the same thing i respect it that's
what we should do that's what everybody
should do that's what
god created us to do to help everyone
for sure
tell me a little bit about the the hall
of fame tell me about the whole thing
you know hall of fame
i'm going to be i in the hall of fame at
22. come on
man i'm going to be one day
that's what i'm really 22
what are you talking about no i'll talk
about one of his albums man
yeah the world hall of fame yeah that's
my album called oh
it's really like me speaking in its own
existence
yeah i just speak into existence all the
time mike i was gonna ask you mike are
you uh
you're inducted to the whole thing
wrestling in boxing
oh yeah wrestling too yeah
[Music]
copped the bmw new deposit i picked up
another bag like
[ __ ] it i'm a cow while i'm in it i have
planes flying crowds screaming money
counter shanks clanging [ __ ] i guess
decided
i ain't joking do it sound like i'm
kidding i've been making like 2 000 a
minute
so high up through the clouds i was
swimming i'm probably gonna drown when
i'm in it
i bet she gonna get loud when i'm in it
and we might have a child
after we [ __ ] she can't get near me only
[ __ ]
[Music]
you know any of those girls for real nah
and i will be helping my friend she will
be my friend forever
you're the disciplined entertainer but
your money
and business huh yeah
that's what it's about handling your
business i'm just talking [ __ ] about the
about handling your business for sure
that you know how many people will be
looking at you in this [ __ ]
ain't nothing like flying private too
commercial huh yeah i wasn't i thought i
was gonna say i wasn't on the set but i
actually was on the plane for that i'm
playing commercial you could see
people talk to people fighting probably
you know you know with your friends
everybody's sleeping and eating
yeah so you saying like you like being
with the people more
yeah i don't like that i talk [ __ ] to
them
and stuff can we it's like on a private
plane the people are too much in my
business i don't like people in my
bedroom like the
the lady what do you call it again it's
the story or the students i don't think
in a small place for a few hours in the
in your business
you don't feel congested when that
happens i feel like the the commercial
flight they just as much in your
business
no i can't see and i could see so many
different people instead of seeing four
people
me and my wife and my kids yeah yeah i
know there's nothing like that i've
actually i've flown private with you
mike
yeah remember you're scolding us on our
way from uh
florida back to no on the way to
minnesota what do
you're scolding us on relationships oh
man i'm somebody that should talk holy
god
you can learn what not to do in your
relationship for me you can't learn what
to do
i don't know but that day you were
scolding us but all of us were just
sitting there like all right
so what are you planning man what are
you doing with your life look i got hall
of fame on the way dropping it
june 11th and i just really been
uh trying to hone in on getting better
as a rapper over the summer
what girl rapper you like to do a song
with
nicki minaj yeah she's really cold yeah
do you like you know her mike i met her
before i don't know her i said hi
she said hi
there's a lot man can we pull up the
goat
yeah let's check the coat out see my mom
he said you don't mess around with those
girls because they're trouble right
yeah yeah
i mean saying that he's a smart man
[Music]
the scenes the way i kill it lose our
voice when she trying to scream we from
the trenches we moved on to the finer
things now you know information
[Music]
he was playing games got you dancing in
the middle of the club got you dancing
in the middle of the club
i know what you chasing you can only get
this feeling from a thug you can only
get this feeling from a thought
tears falling and it's licking your cup
all you really want is love
baby all you really want is love only
talk to bosses independent can't be
[ __ ] with a scrub girl i know you
can't be [ __ ] with a scribe
[Music]
fighting him right back now damn he
[ __ ] you up
that's like the um the martin episode
when he [ __ ] talks
how much do you think you've evolved
mike obviously he's 22 years old you
talk about your shot but then i see your
video i'm like man you could you know
you'd be a good actor too bro yeah
possibly i feel like uh
anything that i have something to do
with it like i try to
damn near perfect it yeah you do a good
job doing that
know i was talking to i was a real
[ __ ]
the nice kid my kid
yeah but how old were you mike when you
won your first world title 20
20 20 yeah
you're still the youngest in history
right mike yeah it's the
[ __ ] yeah it's not steve 20 years old
oh it's what we got to do man let's get
our man out of here man
yeah that's what's up any advice mike
any any closing thoughts from that you
would uh
that you would give listen i think he's
doing everything just as
good as i can ever tell you everything
looks good man
for sure he don't like to talk his
business and stuff but you know honestly
everything looks
good he lost messages apollo g
you talking to millions of people please
no it's good though hall of fame on the
way back y'all know what the [ __ ] going
on
you know what the [ __ ] going on hall
of fame [ __ ]
okay that's it i'm triple c
hey i'm mike tyson bingo
chop a lot polo with the jizzy
we out